birthdays in lockdown can be a little
lonely
but it's not every day you turn 100.
happy birthday dad
oh thank you my darling ray brooks is
delighted with his birthday wishes from
the queen
and his newfound fame fundraising for
charity
since lockdown began ray has cycled for
15 minutes
every single day but due to a slight
technical fault he doesn't actually know
how far that is in total
i haven't got a clue because my bike's
so old the monitor's broken
so i can't measure the mileage but i do
15 minutes every day
and i i
can't imagine how many miles that comes
to it would be nice to find out
i wonder how many times around the isle
of wight that would be oh quite a few i
should think
he says he's lucky daughter trudy lives
nearby
started off five minutes and built up to
10 minutes and then built up to 15.
and i was talking to my sister and we
said
well why don't you do it for charity dad
raymond charles
jules brooks served for six years in the
british army
joining up in 1938 he spent part of the
second
world war in the middle east before
landing with his regiment
on the first day of the invasion of
sicily one year before d-day
he's already beaten his fundraising
targets for macmillan nurses
and a charity which supports blind
veterans who've lost their sight in
service
i was injured in 2006 in iraq uh i got a
shot right into the face
uh left cheek right um
and after all the sort of prognosis was
i'd lost my left eye
and my right eye was severely damaged i
think raymond
you know 100 years old uh you know start
a lot down
he didn't feel sorry for himself he just
he just decided to do something positive
uh and that that inspires me to get up
and do something positive you know i'm
less than half his age and if he's going
to do it
what's my excuse ray says his cycling
was inspired by this man the late
captain tom moore
a man whose daily walking captured the
hearts of the nation
and raised millions of pounds for nhs
charities
like ray in the run-up to his 100th
birthday
raymond's lockdown story like captain
tom's before him
is exactly what we need to hear to
counter the seemingly never-ending
deluge
of bad news two men heroic in their
military service
and now heroic again in a different way
ray intends to carry on cycling into his
second century
and his secret to reaching a hundred
years
i haven't got a clue i have a whiskey
every night if that's anything to go by
it's an amazing thing to get there i'll
give him a big hug
harriet hadfield sky news on the isle of
wight